we are going to begin by reading an
excerpt chapter from chapter 11 that is
the adulthood chapter of our forthcoming
book a hunter-gatherer's guide to the
21st century there are 13 chapters in
this book so we are coming up
on the end of these excerpts which means
we're also coming up on publication date
which is just two and a half weeks away
at this point september 14th types of
reality
remember while e coyote whose life's
work was chasing the roadrunner in
looney tunes cartoons
in hot pursuit he often found himself
skidding off the edge of a cliff where
he would hang suspended in air until he
looked down
gravity did not apply until he
recognized that it should
it was funny because it was ludicrous
it was utterly ludicrous and yet too
many modern people seem to imagine that
by changing people's opinions or
perspectives you change underlying
reality
in short they believe that reality
itself is a social construct
we argued earlier that con artists and
the confused often operate on a holy
social plane rather than on an
analytical one
how do you avoid becoming someone who
assesses the world based on social
responses rather than based on analysis
one of those people who are easily
fooled by con artists and the confused
two good strategies are to regularly
engage with the physical world and to
understand the value of close calls
the sad truth is that the more educated
you are today the harder this is to do
our current higher education system is
steeped in a philosophy that doubts our
ability to even perceive the physical
world that philosophy is called
postmodernism
postmodernists have been at the leading
edge of promoting the view that reality
is socially constructed
post-modernism and its ideological child
post-structuralism were once contained
in a small corner of the academy
these ideologies do contain kernels of
truth they teach us for instance that
our sensory apparatus biases us and that
we are mostly unaware of those biases
they reveal that school factories and
prisons are similar in their use of
power to control populations that was an
analysis done by michelle foucault in
his metaphorical extension of bentham's
panopticon
and critical race theory has at its
foundation the real observation that the
american legal system has had a
particularly difficult time emerging
from its racist past
and
and the full recovery from that past is
not yet on the horizon
these are a few real and valuable
contributions that such ideologies have
contributed to the world but most modern
instantiations of postmodernism have
jumped the shark
sometimes when fringe academic ideas go
rogue they persist longer than they
might but their impact is limited to a
few university departments
not so with postmodernism and its
downstream effects
what what happens on campus has most
definitely not stayed on campus
postmodernism and its adherence have
infiltrated systems far beyond higher ed
from the tech sector to k-12 schools to
the media and are doing considerable
harm
one of the most astounding conclusions
of some postmodernists is that all of
reality is socially constructed they
have taken they've even taken issue with
the conclusions of newton and einstein
on the basis of the privilege of these
scientists is obvious in their equations
and as old white guys their biases
inherently prevented them from knowing
anything real of the world
people of particular phenotypes this
ironically biologically deterministic
and regressive worldview argues can't
possibly have access to truth
how do you come to be this confused
though to believe that all reality is
socially constructed
have little experience in the real world
no carpenter or electrician could
believe that all of reality is socially
constructed no forklift operator or
sailor could
nori would have thought could any
athlete
there are physical ramifications of
physical actions and everyone operating
in the physical world knows this
if you have not thrown or caught many
balls or used hand tools or laid tile or
driven stick shift in short if you have
little or no experience with the effects
of your actions in the physical world
and therefore have not had occasion to
see the reactions they produce
then you will be more prone to believing
in a holy subjective universe in which
every opinion is equally valid
every opinion is not equally valid and
some outcomes don't change just because
you want them to
social outcomes may change if you argue
or throw a fit
physical outcomes will not
everyone no matter how trapped they are
in their body with its particular flaws
and strengths has the opportunity to
experience the world of actions and
reactions in the physical world
not everyone can bike singletrack but
for those of us who can and do we face
objective reality in the form of roots
hills and gravity how given your
particular body might you force your
mind and body into confrontation with
physical reality
consider this
our eyes do not produce a static image
like a photograph rather our eyes are
tools of our brains taking note of the
world we are fully embodied our bodies
are not afterthoughts to our brains or
unnecessary to their interpretation of
the world those eyes and those skulls on
those necks atop those torsos and legs
and feet that move it is all part of
perception perception is an action
the more you move therefore within
whatever your particular limits are the
more integrated whole and accurate your
perception of the world is likely to be
movement increases wisdom
so too does exposure to diverse views
experiences and places we need both
freedom of expression and freedom to
explore because both speak to the value
of environments in which outcomes are
uncertain
nature is still available to us let us
spend time in it and in so doing
generates strength and calibrate our
understanding of our own significance
humans are evolved to be antifragile
we grow stronger with exposure to
manageable risks with the pushing of
boundaries fostering openness to
serendipity into that which we do not
yet know
this is true for both bones and brains
doing things with non-negotiable
outcomes in the physical world
skateboarding growing vegetables
ascending a peak provides a corrective
to many wrong-headed ideas currently
passing for sophisticated some of these
include all of reality is a social
construct emotional pain is equivalent
to physical pain and life is or can be
made perfectly safe
a graduate school mentor of ours george
estabrook who was primarily a
mathematical ecologist but who also
spent many years of field seasons
working and living with the
practitioners of a traditional
agricultural system in the hills of
portugal wrote this in the introduction
to one of his papers quote
it is remarkable how the persistent
empiricism of human beings struggling to
make their living in nature results in
practices that make ecological sense
even though they may be codified in
ritual or explained in ways that seem
superficial or not compelling
ecologically
indeed local practitioners may have
concepts equally justifiable but very
different from those of academics of
what constitutes a useful explanation
end quote
if we were forced to choose between the
useful explanation given to us by a
villager versus one provided by your
average academic about an object that
the villager depended on for her
sustenance we would surely choose the
villager's explanation
here we reference part of the
introduction that we haven't yet shared
with you guys that costa rican villager
who likely saved our lives by keeping us
out of a rapidly rising river whom we
talked about in the introduction knew
far more about where we were and how to
interpret the signs than we budding
academics did
you can fool a person and they can fool
you but you can't fool a tree or a
tractor a circuit or a surfboard so seek
out physical reality not just social
experience
pursue feedback from the vast universe
that exists beyond other human beings
watch your reactions when the feedback
comes in
the more time you spend pitting your
intellect against realities that cannot
be coerced with manipulation or sweet
talk the less likely you are to blame
others for your own errors
that's the excerpt for today yes
it is interesting how
events preceding a pace
since we completed
the book
uh
seem to
reflect well on many of the things that
we described as generalities in there
there's just so much of the
modern circumstance that um is
reflective of exactly
these kinds of um delusions so once
again the first draft was uh submitted
in march of 2020 just as code was
beginning to descend on the planet
right so um i i am
uh inspired to add one thing that is not
contained in that uh that excerpt yeah
this should be a living document um
the
it is ancient that people should um have
the sense
that their desire for something to be
true if they can only put enough will
behind it affects the uh the truth of
what is correct and that obviously isn't
so
um what we are seeing now
involves a sort of second tier now no
doubt this has ancient origins as well
but there is not only the attempt to
force reality to bend to one's desires
but
we are seeing an industrial strength
campaign now to shift the measurement of
what has taken place so that it will
reflect well on the belief that one can
force something to be by willing it to
be yeah
and this is very it's a very dangerous
kind of transition because
um
the problem is in order to get better we
have to see the error of our ways if the
record of what took place is altered so
that it reflects well on the
myopia and blind spots of those who
arrogantly pushed us in the direction of
a policy
then uh we aren't an ability in a
position to um correct our trajectory
and actually i'm uh
many things are happening at once
obviously in the world what's taking
place in afghanistan i think reveals the
full depth of the hubris of this system
of governance right that um
apparently we you're not you're talking
about the system of governance that we
are engaged in or that they were engaged
no no our system of governance led us
obviously into a uh a situation we
fought for almost a generation
and
the
gains whatever they might have been are
reversed within hours or
days um that suggests that whatever
stories we were telling ourselves
were not grounded in in reality um in
this well
at least they weren't stable
uh or they they needed more work to
become stable well let's put it this way
presumably i mean
the women's and girls lives were were
improved over the last 20 years in
afghanistan
uh and and
that is that is disappearing right but
we were not we were not those of us in
the society that uh that launched into
this campaign were not told that what we
were doing was temporarily staving off
um
an evil that would descend again as soon
as we left right we were led to believe
that we were accomplishing something and
then we were led to believe that it was
stable
and the opposite has turned out to be
true so i have no doubt that it was um
better to exist in afghanistan
under our temporary rule but the point
is
there was nothing accomplished it was a
matter of treading water at least if
this is the way uh that we left so
in any case
yes certainly given given the way that
we we left that's a disaster and i think
um
you know there's there's a general
question here which is to the extent
that something takes control and decides
to
mislead us
into
um
pleasant fictions about what our power
in the world might be what we might
accomplish what it will cost
all of these things at the point that we
finally get our comeuppance uh it is an
extremely rude awakening and the
question is how much better off would we
be if we had a system that made an
attempt at least to be honest with us in
real time about what the actual costs of
something are what might actually be
accomplished what are the real risks of
doing this well just as
just as compulsory schooling
was in part
explicitly intended in its origins in
germany and to a large part we we
inherited those intentions when
compulsory schooling uh took hold in
sort of around the turn of the last
century
uh
was to create a populace that was easily
controlled
that you know as as populations grew and
as industrialization and mechanization
grew
uh it was
valuable to employers to have a a
workforce
that didn't ask too many questions
and
um
i have not heard it argued explicitly
that it is valuable to a government
that is
that proclaims its democratic intentions
in both its founding texts and in its
current politicians
that it is valuable to have a populist
that is under-informed and yet that is
clearly
uh implicit in the policies uh and the
ways that policies are handed down and
the you know the kinds of the kinds of
proclamations like hashtag follow the
science
except we're not going to tell you
anything but the conclusions that
unnamed experts behind closed doors have
arrived at that's not that's not
following the science that's following
the authorities and that's not
scientific right and the implication is
that the authorities um
actually have a better vantage point and
that their interests are synonymous
enough with with ours that what they
tell us is at least a good shot at
what is liable to be the right direction
and the very frightening problem is that
once you establish
this relationship that experts will
decide something you won't be able to
check it or even understand
who they are what motivates them but
it's supposed to be in your interest
it will inevitably be captured and what
is fed to you as the truth as seen by
experts will be propaganda and the
problem is that you are endangered by
the very fact that there is
an engine of propaganda empowered to
dress up like experts and tell you what
it thinks yeah um and you know that's
where we are and so yeah it's wearing
the couture of science without being
science it is the co-tour of science it
is cargo cult science uh as feynman yes
would uh would put it and did put it and
the problem is you know yes it's all
well and good to describe it as cargo
cult science but the real point is what
is the danger of such a thing and the
danger of such a thing is proportional
to the seriousness of the matters that
are being navigated by this
pseudo-scientific
process and so
you know i don't want to draw the
connection
too closely but i do think
that to the extent that there is
anything positive to be derived from the
afghanistan situation at all
it is
the recognition
that the system that was capable of
making errors this big is in charge of
many other things in which you are not
in a position to see it unfold on your
screen and so the question is all right
that thing
was certainly so radically incompetent
that it could not possibly be entrusted
with anything important right it
obviously and i'm not regarding what
took place in afghanistan as anything
but of the utmost importance but the
point is
that was important that was clearly
lives on the line um and you know the
fate of a people on the line
and
we see how well it played out we can see
you know the hubris unfolding um in
in graphic terms but the question is
what also looks like that that is not so
visible or so easy to monitor and
you know
uh
many
many things are of great importance at
the moment we are navigating many
uncharted
waters and
i don't see any evidence that there's a
great deal more competence than what was
in charge in afghanistan in charge of
for example
coveted policy
and so you know people need to think
about that it's at least a question what
if the what if the thing that made this
error is also making errors with respect
to covet that are equally as as
terrifying at the end of most of the
chapters in this book we have something
called the corrective lens
in which we provide you know actionable
suggestions um that follow from some of
the analysis and stories that we've
provided in the rest of the chapter this
one the corrective lens items on this
chapter are long i was considering
reading all of them but i think i won't
read all of them
but there are a couple that are
particularly salient i think given the
conversation we just had
the first one is
explicitly aimed to be an adult do this
in part by regularly asking yourself the
questions that we post at the beginning
of the chapter for instance am i taking
responsibility for my own actions am i
being closed-minded and by minimizing
the effects of economic markets on your
daily life
become aware of the constant flow of
information telling you what to think
how to feel and how to act do not let it
into your mind do not let it steer at
you your internal reward structure needs
to be independent and ungamable that
independence in turn should allow you to
collaborate well with others who are
similarly independent be wary of those
who may well be nice but who are
captured
um
there's a lot there's i think these are
all good we wrote them um
four more
smile at people
the people with whom you live the person
behind the counter the stranger on the
street
put your phone down
no really put it down
define your fights for whom and what you
love rather than against whom and what
you hate
if a mob ever comes for people you know
people whom you consider friends stand
up and say no you're wrong
be honorable and courageous when bullies
move in speak up for what you know to be
true even if it makes you a social
pariah
and finally uh apropos the discussion of
diminishing returns curves uh which we
don't have a picture of here but we do
in the final chapter of the book learn
to jump curves
diminishing returns are a factor for
every complex phenomenon so learn to
jump curves put another way consider
learning a new thing rather than being a
perfectionist and trying to get ever
better at whatever you are already
really really good at
[Music]